hairy one of the things we discover in
both in loogan axes that Luke seems to
become
geography I think not intuitive
geography lessons but the kind of
organizing principle to bring his themes
together and and for these passages
we're looking at now Jesus is on a very
long and somewhat convoluted trip to
Jerusalem and as he goes my sense is
that he takes time to instruct his
disciples on some of the main themes
that he thinks they will need to
remember as they move from his presence
to his presence in heaven and we see
some of those themes here he tells them
how they are to confess him even when
they're under threat and some sense the
discipleship will never be easy there's
more contemplation about the
relationship between wealth and poverty
with the fool who puts all his stuff
together and says now my soul take your
rest and Jesus has God saying God speaks
again here incidentally guy doesn't
speak often directly in in God's most
direct way you stupid fool what what are
the themes you think that that Luke is
holding out for the nascent church to be
thinking about as Jesus gives them these
kind of parting instructions right
you've hit a couple of major things that
are going on here it's rather difficult
in these chapters of Luke in the center
of the the long journey to Jerusalem to
see a simple theme at account annuity
Luke seems to bounce back and forth and
he's probably picking up material from
different sources there's material in
here for instance that reminds us of the
Sermon on the Mount in Matthew the
lilies of the field passage for instance
in Luke 12 22 following that we find in
in Matthew 6 so Lucas getting material
from different places and sort of
organizing it here in a kind of
spiraling way but he does seem to touch
on a few key things and and you've
mentioned them one the cost of
discipleship you have to reckon what
it's going to take to be a follower of
Jesus and sometimes it's a very heavy
cost a little later on we'll hear that
you have to hate your father your
mother's in Luke 14 25 and 26 whoever
comes to me and does not hate father and
mother wife and children brothers and
sisters yes even life itself cannot be
my disciple that's pretty heavy shot
very everything and it's much more
pointed than the parallel in in Matthew
10 which says
if someone loves father and other more
than me copy mothers are usually
different this is one of those points
where you begin to wonder which is the
original version of Jesus saying and I
think the lupine one I probably is it's
easier to see you waited one that's
write it down then rather to make it
this has a little more punch me so is in
any case this is one of the themes that
it runs through these chapters dont
preach that for Mother's Day that one
wouldn't be a temptation the other theme
is wealth and poverty and again this is
interwoven and so we have the radical
call in Luke 1433 as part of one of
these sections cost of discipleship so
therefore none of you can become my
disciple if you do not give up all your
possessions and that's pretty strong
very strong stuff and then you know
we'll have to keep that in mind when we
see some examples of Jesus encountering
sinners who involve themselves in the
misuse of wealth and after us does he
always articulate that call that seems
to be you know in the Catholic tradition
would be called a council of perfection
yes which is somehow to be qualified in
a pastoral sense when you're actually
deal with concrete individuals and in
some ways Luke exemplifies that that
tendency to have the strong ideal out
there but then to have what you actually
do it is somewhat more modest John the
bed that John the Baptist things don't
stop being a tax collector but stopped
extorting money either that'll Lucas
just inconsistent or hate it consists of
yeah probably are but of little Gospels
right you mentioned the parable of the
rich fool and that's definitely a in
Luke chapter 12 an example story right
usually keeping things in in the right
perspective and not putting this
investing yourself right not that you
can't have anything but if you invest
your soul in what you have then you've
lost it and you can see how Luke it is
there's a bit of an artfulness in the
way Luke juxtaposes some of these
passages so he takes the story of the
rich fool which we don't have in the
other sonority Gospels and puts it right
next to they have don't worry about
clothing yeah we have a feel package so
the two compliments very nice you know
interesting away and jesus also reminds
his disciples that you know it's not
easy going you're going to cause some
division you you are going to be setting
some boundaries by following in my
footsteps people are not going to be all
harmony and light around in Luke chapter
12 49 I think part of it is we need to
we lose first century context so easily
I mean my mother and my father and
brothers and sisters all went to church
with me but when I talked to people in
first generation Christians hate may be
a strong word but real family division
takes place when one of these
confucianism or Buddhism or any other
religion or non religion at all that the
annoyed atheist parents whose son in a
case we both know wandered off to
seminary they never did figure that out
right in any case these these themes
will be picked up again in acts and that
the divisions of my people who respond
positively Jesus a message is something
that Luke will be concerned about
throughout all the way through yeah okay
we've got this fascinating story in here
about following a not following which is
a story of a banquet in the middle of
chapter 14 somebody throws a banquet and
then all the usual invitees expected
invitees don't show up and so what
happens and what does that mean for us
in terms of Jesus ministry and message
here we have another one of Jesus
well-known parables and we have it
tested for us in in three different
sources to in the canonical New
Testament here in Luke 14 and also in
Matthew 22 and then also in the
non-canonical gospel of thomas and in
each case it seems to have a slightly
different point a slightly different
phone which illustrates the principle
that we saw before of parables in
particular having multiple possible
meanings that can be actualized in
different kinds of context just for
contrast at Matthew and Matthew 22 seems
to be focusing on the on this is a
parable of life in the church Matthew is
big yeah yeah very huge on live in the
church yeah and as a kind of coda to the
parent what we have a a little story of
the wedding garment that's as well right
and so it's cast in in Matthew as a
wedding feast
than a general banquet and someone gets
in who doesn't have the appropriate
garment and you know is going to be
punished for my wife's worst fear of
going out to dinner with me you know
it's the dress code no contar Lee yeah
Luke doesn't seem to have that concern
that is not thinking about church order
and sorting out they wheat from the
chaff within the church but really
focusing on one of his key themes a kind
of radical inclusiveness of radical
compassion for those who are poor or
needy so the story goes someone gave a
great dinner not a marriage Roy fees but
registered in our ordinary banquet and
invited lots of people all of whom have
good excuses and then so the master
sends out twice his slaves to get get
people to fill the places at this dis
banquet so one of the things I think
Luke has in mind is his reading of
salvation there is a reflection on the
theme that's going to occupy acts of the
relationship between this new community
of believers and those who reject and
we've seen this before at a couple of
points in look that elements of the the
teaching and action of Jesus foreshadow
what's going to happen in the life of
the church and I think this parable is
in some ways structured to foreshadow
that right and at the same time it's
structured to reinforce what Luke has
been talking about in many cases that
the gospel is focused on compassion on
outreach and to the surprise of the
marginal cost ya and so I think that's
he or two or so once again we have this
this complexity about parables the
multiple factors that you can see even
within the Lucan context and I think
what's interesting about Luke is that he
is sensitive to the the multiple
meanings of parables in a way that I
think Matthew is not all right that's
right Matthew tends to analog arise the
the parables and this means that Miss
immunity is right and Luke is a little
reticent about three cases contradict
this is an example of that is there any
way in which you think 1st century
people read this is that the lake covers
with the Gentiles and the first two sets
of meditations went to the Jews and now
it lasts for bringing the Gentiles in it
could be Jew Samaritans and Gentiles
yeah
yeah but yeah I mean it there is that
that structuring of the story of the
church in acts yeah the message goes out
first of the people in Jerusalem and
then to the Samaritans and then finally
to the Gentile and there's resistance
almost at every step away but
nonetheless the spirit moves things
along and moves it to at that great a
boundary remember that that's part of
the kind of overall structuring of the
whole narrative of Luke and acts to give
it a kind of geographical framework that
full afterlife yeah well [ __ ] in the
gutter would focus stars in russula yeah
and then everything winds up there then
it's like the Big Bang exactly at the
resurrection well things go out and Luke
draws the stage yeah after the excellent
area that early antioch and rome and so
there's something of that I think hinted
at miss Paris so at the end of the story
when Paul's in Rome and of Luke and acts
is Jerusalem still in or if we left
Jerusalem behind and we're now gospel
for the Gentiles only it's rather
interesting it seems to me that the book
of Acts ends in a way that's similar to
the parable of the Good Samaritan
nothing to merit the prodigal son and
we're going to be talking about that
next so I'll wait okay talk about the
fair enough the prodigal son before give
anyone answer all right but it's
interesting on Jerusalem that in the
context of the the powerful of the great
supper in Luke 13 we have the saying of
Jesus about Jerusalem as a place where
profits are killed yeah picking up that
theme of Jesus as a prophet and
successors our profits Jerusalem is the
focal point of his ministry something
that we've heard about on a journey to
jerusalem and jerusalem is somehow
standing under some sort of judgments of
its rejection is lament at the time of
the triumphal entry which will come to
in a few minutes right right so there
there is that that element in Luke but I
don't think it's quite as final as some
would make it be all right thank you